there are no plan to fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit please use either the
fire exit through the main doors of the
hall or the fire exit in the store room
adjacent to the stage the fire assembly
point is the island on the front of the
main entrance to the building please do
not delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do
served by Council staff please know that
the meeting will be live streamed please
switch off mobile phones or turn them to
silent and toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
thank you
members we have quite a full agenda so
just a reminder please keep your line of
questioning or your comments succinct
and to the paper that's okay a gender
item one apologies for absence I have
apologies here from counselor Milne and
councilor Mrs Gadson is there anybody
else
thank you agenda item two there are no
substitute members
gender item three non-members attending
uh councilor is is an attendance
gender item four minutes of the meeting
held on the fourth of sorry the 5th of
July 2023 are the minutes agree members
agreed lovely thank you
the gender item five to receive
Declarations of Interest members are
there any Declarations of Interest
nobody is indicating thank you
the gender item six over the overview of
Housing and homelessness across the
rupture District Council
um members I will now invite Lauren
stretch the council's director for
housing to introduce this report
uh good evening all so um at the request
of members and the chairman of this
committee
um this report gives a general overview
of Housing and homelessness across the
Rochford district and you will have this
report in front of you and there's
nothing new to to note in it um to add
to this and so I'll bring you to the
recommendations which were to note the
information contained in uh within the
appendices of this report and make any
recommendations in line with the
information contained within the report
I'm happy to take any questions that you
might have
thank you members are there any
questions
uh Council across
[Music]
um page 6.5 4.1
facing homelessness is stressful is
there a timeline for the triaging system
and letting applicants know also could
officers advise what support is given if
the eviction date is known for example
if their eviction date is end of October
what measures to make it as fluid and
less stressful for the persons for a
family to prevent homelessness
thank you Lauren
so there are timelines set out within
the law within from the homeless
reduction act so for example duties kick
in uh to assist someone to prevent their
homelessness 56 days and before they are
likely to become homeless and however I
would say that within Rochford the
service goes beyond above and kind of
Beyond this so when a homeless
application
um is made we make contact and triage
all applications within a couple of days
regardless of how far in the future and
the person may be facing homelessness
and appointments are given to those in
need as quickly as we can and that's
usually within a couple of days and it's
my belief that the kind of quicker that
you are able to assess and provide
advice the more likely a positive result
would be reached and and so therefore
better for the resident and even if a
duty is not owed the earlier we make
somebody aware of this
um and what options are available to
them then the more time they have to
make arrangements and it's not always
possible to prevent people's
homelessness but where the council does
our duty to assist
um we'll always look to provide that
necessary advice and assistance as quick
as possible so for example that's
sometimes um rented by in advance in a
deposit and obviously if you can tell
people that that is on offer to them
then they've got a better chance of
securing accommodation
thank you does that answer your question
Council cross it absolutely does thank
you Jim lovely thank you uh councilor
Wharton
thank you madam chairman uh and thank
you for our most informative report
um uh a particularly welcome table uh at
1.3 sitting at the uh Housing
Association providers across the
district
um straightforward question we know uh
that when a significant amount of our
housing stock transferred to Sanctuary
there are obligations on them to provide
a certain volume of Housing and have
growth what obligations are there on
housing associations to expand uh their
supply how does that actually work in
practice
in reality and they are um a business
and an organization within their own
right so there are no obligations for
them to extend and obviously they are
under kind of the same Financial
Obligations as a local Authority so they
would only do so where that makes sense
and they are able to
um I'd point out at this point that that
is going to become quite difficult for
people to expand in the current markets
um it is with everybody including
housing associations
thank you does that answer your question
Council Lawton thank you very much
indeed thank you uh councilor Mrs Belton
thank you and I have two questions if I
may
um so my first question relates to 6.3
item one and the Housing Association
stock
um we don't have any details in here
regarding void properties for each of
the housing associations now I know
obviously the void situation is down to
the Housing Association specifically but
do we do anything to ensure that the
targets are met and we all know of a
number of word properties throughout the
district and if they were turned around
much quicker the numbers on our list
would be shorter and we'd need less home
so I just want to understand what we the
council are doing to enforce that
yeah
okay
yeah so I'll just give you a bit of
background though just to sort of give
you some level of reassurance that well
as much as I can so nationally there is
evidence to show that void turn around
times are going up
um and there are several reasons for
that and so often the the health and
safety regulations have increased around
properties at the moment and so the
requirements on people
um to bring something up to a little
standards and have increased and there
are obviously large
um staff shortages plus Building
Material shortages so so nationally
that's that's not something unique to
the Rochford District that is nationally
the picture
um I am meeting regularly with the
housing associations and that are
operating locally and specifically the
ones that have a lot of stock here and
and this is something that we are
continuing to raise with them and they
assure me that obviously they would not
want to leave properties emptier for
longer than is necessary because they
have income Targets on the lettable
stock and but they do have to make sure
that properties are habitable and
meeting letting standards and a health
and safety compliant before they can be
returned and unfortunately at the moment
they are having to use their resources
to make sure four blocks are compliant
as well
to silence your first question it does
thank you and then my second question
it's on the same vein um page
6.75.6 relating to re-housing into the
private sector
um Southend city council have a robust
policy when it comes to empty homes in
the private sector
um I'll watch for doing anything to
ensure that we don't have private rented
Properties or privately owned properties
that are sat empty for long periods of
time and what are we doing to
incentivize landlords to getting those
into use
okay so um empty homes sits under my
clothes uh Miss Lily but I will answer
that um because I do know a little bit
about this so um we do have an empty
home strategy that was adopted in 2015.
um it details that officers will
consider the use of enforcement action
but only after all avenues to encourage
the owner to bring the property back
into you to have been exhausted and the
council's approach to date has been more
in informal
um owners of entity properties are
contacted by letter making them aware of
their option encouraging them to bring
the property back into use and I believe
that over a hundred visits were carried
out
um each last year to specifically
prioritize sites and with a kind of
proactive approach of targeting that
information to the owners of kind of
long-term minty homes and so if
applicable the owners were made aware
that there are well homes empty property
grants for certain works that are
available to help them bring the homes
back into use in return for us having
nomination rights for a limited period
of time and as always residents are
always encouraged to report empty homes
via the dedicated web page or email so
that we can carry out that work and try
and encourage them back into use
does that answer your questions yes
thank you lovely thank you um Council
award please
thank you Jeremy
um it's actually on the cost
of such things as bed and breakfast and
all the rest of it and looking at
6.6.6.6 uh 5.4 going on to 5.5
uh looking at all the various
how can I put it monies that are going
out of the council to support
homelessness has it been considered that
we could have a remedy in Council owned
modular accommodation is this being
looked at and has there been a review to
look at the cost balance of money going
out and actually having our own
accommodation albeit modular which would
be quick and easy to set up
is that being looked at or has it been
reviewed can we know what you're doing
yes so this year's housing service plan
um is focusing on two kind of key areas
around temporary accommodation so the
first thing that I've brought in is the
review of all ta uh temporary
accommodation placements so we need to
review everybody that's currently in
temporary accommodation some have been
there for a while and look at strategies
we can to move them on into sort of more
permanent accommodation because that
frees up the the accommodation and not
all of it is as costly as bed and
breakfast and the second thing that
really needs to happen is we do need to
understand our true net cost of
temporary accommodation in each of the
options and we don't obviously some is
um we get income back from them and that
obviously offset some of the cost and
then we do need to model the future
demand and looking at all possible
options for accommodation so at this
stage I'd say until that work is done
and we're clearer on future demand and
as the numbers are relatively low in
temporary accommodation across the
district and we need to carefully
consider all options and of which
Council loan temporary accommodation
will just be won and we may also
consider longer term leased
accommodation if the needs arises as
procure an accommodation on a longer
term basis is usually more effective and
as the council doesn't currently own any
purpose-built accommodation it's likely
that you would have to do some
substantial borrowing to purchase any
accommodation even modular units and
with any setup you do need to then look
at the ongoing maintenance aspect
um so um which again is not something
we've currently got in place and so
potentially and that's why we need to do
more work on this that could be costly
and would potentially negate any cost
savings that you're making out of
placing people in bed and breakfast so
it's not a no all options will be
considered but I don't think that we've
mapped enough our future demand to know
what we really need yet
answer your question
the supplementary
do we have is it possible to have a
published cost
of outgoings
as far as bed and breakfast and all the
various other things the cost of
homelessness
to this District
foreign
yes it is possible to do that that's the
modeling at the moment that is happening
for me obviously since I've arrived so
there's two costs there's the costs that
you pay out and then there's obviously
the net cost because there is some money
that you come that you receive back so
some is obviously recovered by benefits
or people can afford it they would have
to make a contribution to that so there
are two separate costs but that that is
definitely something that can be
provided
councilman Mrs Mason
thank you chair yes I would like to Echo
councilor wootton's comment on such a
comprehensive and informative report
um
I would like to just draw your attention
to page 6.4 3.2
it says the last full review of the
Housing Association sorry housing
allocations policy was in 2018
weird now Five Years on there have been
lots of economic social and cultural
changes
and
I wondered when the next
um full review will take place I'm
pleased to hear that there's a review of
temporary accommodation but I do think
that with the time that has passed
um a full review should be implemented
and I would like that observation passed
on to the executive for consideration
thank you
um yeah I mean I would just say that
periodically people do authorities do
usually review their allocations policy
um it is an extensive piece of work you
have to do a lot of consultation around
that so you need to make sure that you
time that in
um in in best place to um because with
other commitments because there is it's
obviously a sensitive topic and you do
actually get quite a lot of consultation
back there is a huge amount that would
need to be done on the equalities impact
assessment
um so yes periodically people do usually
review the allocations policy
um and it has been a while since it's
been done but it just needs to be
programmed in carefully
you'd like to come back counselor yes I
appreciate the officers comments and I
recognize the difficulty so that it
could involve however I think we have an
obligation to our residents to keep our
reviews up to date and I think five
years especially with the changes in the
recent years that we have experienced it
needs to be done so I would like that to
be put into the recommendations on take
wherever
uh 6.1 yeah the reports for noting but I
believe we can add a recommendation so I
will second that thank you thank you
council Mrs Mason uh councilor Mr spirit
thank you Jim
um I've noticed from the report that
we've only got a very limited number of
homeless being accommodated outside our
district has that changed and the reason
behind this is I know somebody who is on
the point of being made redundant not
her own making and she is generally
concerned that her job is in Rayleigh
and if she's relocated it outside the
district
how's her mode of getting back in here
to do the work that she currently does
is there anything that can be done to
take this into account
[Music]
so we will
um In fairness to with across the
district even where people are being
placed outside of the district it is in
like neighboring kind of local areas
um obviously we like everybody else are
facing a struggle to find accommodation
and our main obviously statutory
obligation is to to ensure that somebody
is not homeless and but we will of
course try and do everything we can
around the circumstances if we're able
to do so
[Music]
are there any more questions uh
councilor Mrs Belton
sorry I forgot one of my other questions
um so this relates to page 6.4 item
three
um and that the register essentially now
we talk here about
um the criteria and that a lot of
numbers join via the latter criteria of
working 15 hours per week within the
district and within the strategy which I
haven't read I apologize does it lay out
how we evidence that they work within
the district and is working from home or
mobile working for example taken into
consideration because an office can be
based in the district but someone could
be working much further afield and how
often do we review the list to check
they're still eligible in terms of for
example if it is their employment and
finally if I may the three-year
residency rule if someone was to move
outside of the district for a year or
two for whatever the circumstance may be
does that then mean they start again in
terms of the three-year residency rule
thank you
so yeah so it is verified when they
first join and that's via wage slips and
contracts and we do as much as we can
obviously to to verify that
um we Pro we don't usually verify that
again until they're close to being
successful
um because it would is too much
obviously on the administration to do it
throughout the lifetime you know someone
can be on the housing register for
several years and their employment
status can go up and down but it is
checked at the beginning when they join
to make sure they're eligible and if
they are likely to be successful for a
property we really confirm um those
details
um and with regards to the three-year
residency rule I will have to double
check but I believe
um so certain times they'll do three in
the last five years and and that's in
certain people's allocation policy but I
will confirm that for you
thank you
thank you if there's no more questions
um I just have one and um just one small
typo
um page um 6.3 1.1
um it says that most homes across the
district are privately owned with 88 of
properties classed as own occupier or
without the mortgage there's
approximately six percent of properties
which are privately rented and the
remaining six percent is affordable
housing my question is how does this
measure against other councils in
meeting their housing needs so how are
we doing against other councils please
okay so there are higher levels of home
ownership across this district and that
is more so than some others um in the
local area and
as a result of this that means that
there are is less private rentage
accommodation by the nature of that and
due to the demo this demand it's High
um as there's more residents looking for
a smaller number of properties
um this keeps the rents High
um unfortunately
um and the monthly rent being charged
here is above that of kind of local
housing allowance um which means if
you're in receipt of full housing
benefit
um you would have a shortfall to pay and
you'd have to find that out of your
remaining income that's not unique
um to the Rochford District
um it is in the Southeast
um but it does lead to a particularly
challenging housing market especially
when we are looking for alternative or
residents looking for alternative rented
accommodation
thank you and um it's very small uh
minor typing error on page 6.3 2.2 and
we are a district Northborough that's
all
um any more questions
okay then members we have one
recommendation I'm just going to read
that out and verify that with them
council Mrs Mason
um that the overview Integrity committee
requests that the executive initiates a
review of the housing allocations policy
a fuller review so I'll read that out
again the recommendation members is
the overview and scrutiny committee
request that the executive initiates a
full review of the housing allocations
policy
all those in favor oh did you want to
come in there sorry yeah I would just
like to put the reasons why that the
fact that it has been five years and
because of the cultural social and
economic changes that have been quite
dramatic in that time I think is that we
hadn't experienced the changes that we
have seen I wouldn't be proposing this
but in the light of that I think it's
quite important so I'd like that to be
added into the recommendation please the
reasoning
thank you chair good evening members
um we wouldn't normally build the
reasoning into the recommendation but
obviously this will be referred to the
executive so we can include in the
report that goes to the executive the
committee's reasoning for suggesting
this recommendation are you content with
that yeah
thank you thank you so members all in
favor of the recommendation please raise
your hands
okay
thank you members actually unanimous
and members is the rest of the report
noted
thank you
can I just say uh thank you very much
Lauren thank you for that agenda item
and if you want to go you're most
welcome to
um
[Music]
members uh agenda item seven the cost of
living payments
um just before I pass over to the
officer I just want to make a couple of
comments here
[Music]
so um just a little bit about the
working group I just want to first of
all um just give a little bit more
background than that is in the paper and
the fact that one of the things we were
discussing within the working group is
the group of residents known as Jam
which I learned it means just about
managing
so we need to look after all our
residents those who are really suffering
the impact of the cost of living crisis
and those who possibly are struggling
with it as well
um I want to give credit to councilor
Mrs Gadsden
um the working group met continuously
during the holiday period and she was
there throughout but unfortunately can't
be here tonight and I also want to thank
Tim Willis our director of resources who
put together this report
um in their outstanding time especially
as he had been on his annual leave as
well I will now pass over to Tim to
introduce the report
thank you very much chair
um this report follows a full Council
resolution
to which requested this committee set up
a working group to look at options to
address how council tax customers could
be supported in light of the higher cost
of living and this report presents the
working groups proposals and I'm happy
to help answer any questions there might
be
foreign
members are there any questions
counselor Ward
thank you chairman
um but it's actually there are three
questions I've got here
um
recommendation one
or recommendation two I should say uh
that the interim director resources
allocate seven thousand of the council
tax hardship fund for one-off use in the
current Financial year
I was wondering why there was an
understatement and what information was
available to access the fund
if I probably taken one by one might be
easier
that was the question
um
thanks so I'll ask those two questions
did you wanna
counselor would um if we can let the
officer answer that one and I'll come
back to you for your um further
questions
okay um
so why was there an underspected
available so there's seven thousand
Pounds
um being put on the table here
um
we anticipate that there will be an
under spend based on the levels of
demand in respect to the budgets that
this will be drawn from
um most demand for both the council tax
support fund which I'll talk about in a
moment as well as the the hardship fund
tends to be at the soon after the
billing
um and once the billing has been done
and people realize they may need support
that's normally when all the demand is
and then it tells off during the rest of
the year so we we gain confidence that
there's going to be an unspend on these
sorts of budgets as we as we get this
this halfway through the year Financial
year It's Not Unusual not to fully spend
the hardship fund is
um quite common and the unusual thing
that has happened this year for 23 24 is
the government allocated as 95 000
pounds
but this is called council tax support
fund it's another similar name but it's
specifically available to support people
council tax support and the council
approved 25 pounds up to 25 pounds for
everyone that was on council tax support
out of that 95 000. it's only used 64
000 of it
um so there's that money available as
well and perhaps because there's that
funding it's meant that the hardship
fund hasn't been in as such demand this
year as it might otherwise have as have
been
um we will be taking stock in October as
we normally do in terms of people
struggling to pay their council tax
bills
um and we would look to further to
support residents who are struggling to
pay despite knowing that we still
believe they'll be sufficient underspend
of seven thousand Pounds just in terms
of information there's information on
bills about council tax support scheme
which is the main scheme that is
available
um to support those that are struggling
to pay our website provides details on
how to access council tax support as
well as the hardship fund
um
and the proposed use of the seven
thousand pounds is also to support those
residents in need or be it not direct
financial support
thank you
would you like touch your next question
thank you very much
um you want to arrange a grant award a
seven thousand pound for Road shows to
assist residents
um this goes back to the original
question of what information was
available to access the fund
um
I would like to see this underspend
allocated directly to those in need
surely a better directed advertising
throughout the district would be more
cost effective
the council considers as part of that
budget process the inclusion of ongoing
funding of five thousand pound and just
putting this all together for similar
purposes need to fully understand the
necessity for this spending sum so I'm
just putting those those couple of
things together of using why are you
using the seven thousand ferocious
and also the 5 000 for a similar purpose
the officer come back first and then
perhaps I can give you a little bit more
information from the working group
thanks Jeff
um yes the the working group obviously
had liberations of its own and real
conclusions there before you tonight and
uh I advised the working group um about
the working group came to their
decisions and I'm sure the chair can
who's also the chair in working group
will be able to help out on some aspects
of that
um what the only thing I would add is
that
actually part of the working groups
um requested me were to do some research
um and we did contact another local
Council not that far away from here but
um I promised I wouldn't name
um but after they uh told me what they
told me but they set aside a fairly
large sum of money it was all of their
the the income they generated from
increasing council tax by more than they
had originally planned and because the
cap went up with our referendum
um and they set it aside to invite bids
from people who needed
um to be given grants
um and the take-up was very poor they
put an awful lot of work into
publicizing it and administering it but
the take-up was very important and that
was six months into the scheme so I
think that there is evidence that a
number of people who perhaps councils
would most like to help if they're not
already receiving help through things
like the council tax support they are
quite hard to reach
and so um you can put an awful lot of
effort in and not get much response back
which is I could say one of the one of
the factors that the working group
considered when it was coming up with
ideas as to what it can do to help with
the cost of living crisis
thank you Tim
um so to give you a little bit more
information the council award
um when the working group met
we we talked about what Uber mentioned
about the most needy
but not forgetting there is also a group
of people who are still suffering from
the cost of living crisis who perhaps
don't meet some of the criteria for some
funds we're also looking at the groups
that you mentioned being hard to reach
as Tim mentioned therefore if you put on
an event or invite them to apply well
can they apply how do they get there the
idea around the Roadshow is to go out to
these communities and we're not just
looking at including information now on
the cost of living crisis but it can be
advice around budgeting
cooking on a budget
um the group that the council worked
with the Habit the mega Center have all
the partners that can deliver various
information to them and so we thought
well that on the back of these and 7 000
isn't an unreasonable amount to ask for
somebody to pull something together for
us in this financial year with the aim
to reaching as many people as we can in
our district does that make sense
no
it makes sense as far as that's
concerned I just find that I mean I saw
the working group you know came to their
ideas after listening to everything it
was just the fact that obviously there
are people who are outside of the net
let's say who do not receive the normal
Council thing and they are obviously the
people who don't know how to get
anything I take it those are the people
you are targeting the people who don't
know how to actually approach and get
anything supplementary
[Music]
um yes that group but also anyone so
these Road shows will be for anyone to
go along to and we're hoping that Ward
councilors will be involved in them and
promote them and be there to talk to
people as well
um I don't know if any other members of
the working group wanted to come in at
all you're more than welcome her
councilor Mrs Belton
thank you a couple of points and a
couple of questions and firstly thank
you to councilor McPherson for
mobilizing this working group and
keeping the members of it very well
informed when some of us couldn't attend
um we're always obviously very detailed
explanations of what we'd Miss so that
we could make good decisions
um and thank you to Tim because
certainly the first the first meeting
there was a lot of ideas banded around
and Tim made sure we stayed on track and
and only spoke about things that were
achievable so that we didn't go down the
Garden Path so to speak
um
on a point I think that the seven
thousand pound for the road shows it
will present great value for money if we
try to give seven thousand pound to the
residents most in need they would get a
tough and say each and it would make no
difference but actually if we can get
those roadshows set up and multiple
people can attend the hope would be they
will be able to save much more money
than we would have been able to grant
them essentially and learn behavioral
changes and other benefits to um to
things that are available to them in
this district and around it
um in regards to recommendation for I
was really pleased to see that that's
that was um that's here for us our small
but pretty brilliant team looking after
the cost of living at one of the last
ons meetings requested that if at all
possible they're given a budget because
they don't have one and the only budget
they did have was from the leaders fund
from councilton's leaders fund last year
and that was able to deliver some good
schemes so hopefully we can see some
some repeated that and my question and
given that we are quite a way through
the year is how soon do we think we
could mobilize any additional event
events and will we be able to spend that
seven thousand pound this financial year
um
and I think that's actually my only
question mothers were points thank you
[Music]
um just to say
um uh thank you for all your support in
the working group counselor Mrs Belton
the um
uh you're asking if they're able to
mobilize this in this financial year the
Hub that we have spoken to believe they
can and I'm happy to take their word for
it they've delivered excellent events in
partnership with um our officers in the
past thank you
thanks um
could I just return to the something
that Council Ward said that I just
wanted to cover off which it was linked
partly to our councilor Bill I said too
which is just re-emphasizing something
you said sure that
part of the original objective for the
working group I think was to try and
um Provide support to those that don't
automatically receive support for
example council tax support were there
ways in which direct payments for
example could be made so there's such a
such a such groups of people
um and the conclusion of the working
group was
um that it was just not possible within
the terms of reference of the working
group to do that given the complexities
um involved in assessing potentially
individuals individuals wealth and
circumstances and income
councils including this District Council
isn't set up to administer such a scheme
it already has a scheme which is the
council tax support scheme and to have
another one was considered it would be
way disproportionate in terms of the
administrative costs compared to the
potential benefit of those that we might
be able to help
on the seven thousand Pounds
um it's I was conscious that it was
important the working group brought
something back to the this committee
with a cast eye uncertainty about the
funding being available and I can give
that Assurance I am confident there is
seven thousand Pounds available so that
won't be a reason to hold things up I
think I was also very aware as the
working group was that the conclusion to
set a size seven thousand Pounds for a
grant to fund a Roadshow or Road shows
um is
um it was a laudable and clear
conclusion but that left the work to be
done in order to implement it and
conscious that the officer around it
wasn't around the table or the working
group that was responsible for that
which is Tracy Lilly
um so that is something that I think the
the committee needs to bear in mind that
that what isn't in the report before us
tonight is how we're going to implement
the recommendation is just a
recommendation back which fulfills the
duty of the working group on behalf of
the committee for full Council
Council award
thank you chairman no I appreciate the
depth that has been explained to me in
regards to the reasons and the thinking
behind what went on because that is not
apparent in the report it's just teasing
out and understanding what is behind the
report and I do appreciate what else
about and what you yourself chairman
have added to the debate in regards to
this to give greater clarity as to the
reasoning that that money is being put
in place and I appreciate that thank you
thank you are there any more uh Council
if we can keep it succinct if that's
okay
okay it'll be very succinct it's not a
question actually it's a comment uh
Madam chairman but uh certainly I think
it's worth just going back in history to
the fact that um this all came about as
about as a result of a proposal made in
our budget meeting but at that time it
was an uncosted proposal which
um I think sought the emotional
agreement of all councilors to make sure
that there wasn't a fundamental hole in
not providing for our residents and it
was an uncosted albeit an estimated 300
000 pounds uh potentially being put
aside based on the attlesford
proposals uh I'm delighted that some
months on and under your very excellent
stewardship
um all that has come out and I say all
that has come out is that clearly there
wasn't a huge gap that we were missing
uh so that's really good
um but I really applaud the fact that
we're still attempting to identify
through spending this money remember to
the community so I think a good bit of
work has come out of it I didn't agree
that an um costing item should come to
the budget meeting but I think out of it
has come some really good work done by
the uh by the working group under your
stewardship thank you very much thank
you cancer goodness we can keep it
succinct thank you
uh yeah firstly apologies if I've got
the wrong end of the stick here
um but it's just a team
did I understand you say just now that
if this was recommended or approved uh
Mr President moment in time you don't
know how it will be implemented by the
officers or did I get the wrong
get the wrong end of it
thank you Joe um no I didn't quite say
that okay what I was trying to emphasize
was that the the four Council acquired
the committee to set up a working group
to look at this the working group did so
and so reported back to this committee
and that's what this report is before
before you and the recommendation is it
includes to set out to spend seven
thousand pounds on road shows as in
recommendation three and that's what
you'll be requested to approve like it
isn't to say the working group wasn't
asked to go away and work out how you
could spend seven thousand pounds on
road shows there's a report on that that
sounds a little bit pedantic but I'm
conscious that the working group had to
find time during the holidays to to come
up with a report and then get it written
and before you tonight
um it didn't trouble yourself so much
with implementing the recommendations
the priority around that I think
especially with my guidance was that it
was costed and funded and once that was
in place then we knew it could happen in
theory but then that does leave the
outstanding issue of implementation as
is often the case where the committee
recommends a course of action that's why
you have officers where you need to find
ways to try and make it happen right
okay thank you thank you um our director
Emilio would like to just add some
command governance on this
thank you chair and actually it leads in
nicely from councilor gooding's question
I just wanted to manage members
expectations that recommendations two
and three that are in front of you today
if the committee chooses to adopt those
recommendations they will go to the
executive to then consider before
they're agreed to be implemented so ons
are a recommending committee so it then
needs to go to the executive and at that
stage the executive as part of their
decision making will need to agree the
correct funding source for that pot so
that will include any details around a
grant condition or a grant agreement
that might be attached to that
recommendation four will go directly to
council and and chair if if I may um in
the the answers that you gave you did
refer to an organization
um within the community that may provide
services of this type I just wanted to
make it clear that at this stage there's
no commitment to fund that particular
organization again that will be a
decision for the executive because there
may be other organizations in the
district that might provide similar
services so I just wanted to make it
really clear that there wasn't any
commitment on the part of the council at
this stage thank you chair
[Music]
um just one question then please um when
is the next executive that this can go
forward it is just that we are
approaching the winter cost of living
crisis is still with us and the sooner
that this is ratified or agreed the
better
thank you chair
um there is an executive meeting on the
21st of September there is a standing
item on that agenda of matters referred
from the ons committee and so all being
well if there aren't any issues
preventing it going forward we could put
it into that agenda that agenda has been
dispatched today but because the agenda
item is there it means we can add table
papers to that that agenda item thank
you thank you so members we've got four
recommendations would you like me to
read them all out or
um have you no wonderful are you all
happy to take them on blog
agreed thank you so the four
recommendations which I will read out
now um and then
about him
um recommendation one that the committee
notes the findings of the working group
recommendation too that the interim
directory or resources allocate 7000
from the council tax hardship fund for
one-off use in the current Financial
year recommendation three that the
director of communities and health
arranges for a grant Award of seven
thousand uh for Road shows to assist
residents to access support from them
with the cost of living
a recommendation for the council
considers as part of the 2024-25 budget
process the inclusion of ongoing funding
of 5 000 per annum for similar purposes
all those in favor please raise your
hand
thank you members that is unanimous
so moving swiftly on
um
item
eight
Highway ranges
um
members I will now invite the council's
director of environment Marcus hotton to
introduce this report
thank you good evening members
um I don't have anything forward to
answer the reporter I would like to
express my thanks to the working group
for the contribution to assisting with
putting the report together and then
their patients with the back and forth
females we had to sort of to have the
sort of sort of finalize this but so
thank you have you take any questions
thank you members are there any
questions
councilor fearing
thank you chairman
um a couple of points I think we should
highlight on this working group and it's
not a criticism of the individuals
involved
for the first time in my knowledge we
had lead a counselor a lead counselor
involved at the meeting at this working
group which as I say I've never seen
before I did question this and was
advised that this was perfectly in order
the other point I would like to
highlight chairman is that the working
group all of us came from Rayleigh
which didn't give a very good cover for
the whole District bearing in mind that
the majority I would suggest and Mr hot
might be able to confirm this the vast
majority or a considerable amount of
work undertaken by the highway ranges is
taken outside of rightly and in the more
rural areas
um which leads me on to the comments
regarding the draft proposals to contact
towns and parishes to seek
expressions of interest in relation
obviously to the funding
um I understand the scenario was
involved in it when when County withdrew
the money but
I don't quite know what we're trying to
achieve here by contacting parishes and
towns to see if it appears to contribute
to the
expressions and to support the highway
ranges when potentially the smallest
District or Parish sorry Parish in the
in the district
possibly has the most use of the Rangers
but have the least amount of money and
residents to contribute towards it so
you know what are we trying to do just
find somebody else to find the money
which doesn't seem a very fair way of
doing things
and yet the biggest town or the biggest
number of residents who have the
potential probably use the highway
ranges at least of all but Mr Horton
might be able to advise whether that is
approximately right but
if we're going to go down this sort of
Road
a big place like ready on the number of
times I need somebody probably wouldn't
want to be involved with the highway
Ranger they would still on an ad hoc
basis chairman thank you
[Music]
our officer corrects me um League
members can be part of working groups
and advise they are just merely not part
of the decision-making process
um
and Marcus if you want to take up the
rest of um council's parents questions
and counselors on oh sorry
[Music]
I think it's hard to quantify exactly I
mean certainly um you think the rural
areas have a greater demand
I I think I've needed that data in front
of me to answer accurately against the
sparing uh it's a question of obviously
a lot of the rural areas although need
attention
um many of those areas cannot be
addressed by the highway ranges so if
you recall really the areas are limited
to those are 30 miles now 40 miles per
hour if we get some some sort of um
measures in place occasionally we do
sort of 60 mile per hour rural areas
where the road traffic was put in place
so
um I I would say
um although there's an issue in the
rural areas I I would say something more
evenly spread perhaps than than first
and meets the eye but that's just that's
what's an anecdotal recollection I would
actually need to break down that data by
walled
yeah I pretty much guess what that was
going to be the answer thank you Jim
thank you council Mrs Mason
thank you chair I must admit I have
quite some difficulty with this report
especially the conclusions
um the report summary starts off by
saying
they expose the possibility of further
sources of funding then it says all
through drawing down the southeast Essex
partnership Surplus funding yet further
running the report it states that there
was 186 000 pounds returned which
represented 11 years which is roughly
seventeen thousand a year and yet in the
report it states that the cost of the
highway ranges is estimated to go up to
about 80 000 so I don't think that's
realistic and I also think it's
concerning because certainly in my world
I've got issues with South Essex parking
partnership outstanding and I believe
other members have as well so I'm a bit
concerned when there's issues that
should be addressed through that body
that apparently aren't being addressed
but we're getting money back and not the
service perhaps that we would expect
secondly
the issue of parishes
a lot of the parishes do anyway can't
maintain Open Spaces a lot of them have
staff some of them certainly do and some
of them in particular I think has a
stunning amount of equipment
and I do believe that it's up to the
parishes how they wish to allocate their
funds in their districts in their
parishes I should say not districts
excuse me there so again I have a
problem
slight problem with that I don't mind
them being asked but I think it's an
unrealistic expectation
the fundamental problem with the highway
ranges is that it's no Duty on this
Council to provide it this Council has
very
shall we say restricted and difficult
Financial circumstances at the moment
and I hope that all members are aware of
the potential problems that are coming
up and with that in mind I don't think
that this Council can afford to spend
eighty thousand pounds on a service that
we're not obliged to provide this is
double taxation on our residents it is
not we they will be paying for it
through Essex
and also through us
I noticed that the report says publicity
people think it's Rochford District
Council they don't
the public actually are totally confused
it's not that they consider it's us
because I get most of the phone calls
from our district so I know most of them
think it's Essex or they ask for
clarification some think it's us I think
if we do not undertake this service the
clarity of information will be much
better we can then sign Point people to
the responsible Authority and there's no
reason why we can't put information on
our websites
so the clarity of message needs to be
done and so I do not support
um the basics of this report I'm happy
to note it but I'm not happy to support
the recommendations and I think we owe
it to our residents to be very
financially prudent thank you
thank you and Marcus did you want to
come back on some of the clarification
around the figures
foreign
it's a one-off payment that would have
covered the budget for another year I
think the recommendations mentions 24 25
doesn't suggest that it could cover that
Beyond there and like I say it is uh
there is a financial gap that needs
addressing in the longer term but and it
it's it's for members to make that
decision I said there has always been uh
concerned in the longer term and then
there may be an issue to finance this
hence a review of The Open Spaces
budgets as well to see whether values
could be used to help fund that in the
longer term but you're absolutely right
it does cost about 80 000 pounds a year
um the set Surplus would fund it for
this year which is doing so and for next
year at the best and then after that you
have a decision to make again but it's
it's the view of the working group at
the time I think there's that there was
an intention to at least try and keep
service going for long as possible
you want to come back and submissive
Mason yeah so I'm going to come back on
on Mr Hudson's
um
disposal of the 186 I know that we've
spent some of it
um my understanding was it was the
a portfolio holder the previous
portfolio holder had other schemes in
mind for the rest of that balance
um I assume it's not been spent as
you're suggesting goes from the I don't
think we should use that money I do
think that we have greater demand I
would actually rather see it going cost
of living because that's where we have a
great need we don't have a great need to
double taxation our our residents
um
in this way and I don't think it's
justifiable
uh cancer Mrs Mason oh sorry council Mrs
Belton
thank you
um no problem few points um
I actually disagree with councilor Mrs
Mason on a number of items there
um I don't disagree with the double
Taxation and the fact that this falls
under Essex County Council but I think
ultimately residents want the work done
I take a number of calls about
constantly Pavements overgrown Hedges
weeds so on and so forth
um
residents are confused they don't
understand a lot of residents are
confused and don't understand the three
tiers of local government and who's
responsible but ultimately they just
want somebody to get the job done
um I was at Hockley Parish meeting just
this week where they realized they've
been undertaking work that they
shouldn't have for quite some years and
they're now not prepared to do so
anymore so they'll be speaking to the
district and County to understand that
I believe that we have a responsibility
to Residents that if the county are
going to stop this service we have to
find a way to fund it and I think if
it's going to cost 80 000 a year we need
to we need to factor that money into our
budgets to deliver it because messy
District creates unhappy residents and
whilst there are many other items and
many other things within our remit that
we could spend the money on this is one
that I think all of us around this table
probably take quite a few calls about we
see it constantly on social media people
challenging the overgrown Hedges and
this year has been particularly wet and
I think that's possibly created more
complaints than usual
um and there's a there's an expectation
that the Rangers have actually already
gone because of the county cut in the
budget but we know that's not the case
because the set funding was put there
and my question though just relates to
items two three and four sorry
recommendations two three and four are
there any time frames on any of these
and I think a further report we brought
back to
um the next overview and scrutiny
committee uh because I think there's
some urgency on this in terms of making
a decision so I said I don't I think we
can you know obviously done some
background work because it's affiliate
all these reports coming forward so I'd
want to bring that forward fairly
quickly
um the draft price at the circulated
parish and town councils can be I mean
if if people wish us to do so we we can
we can go forward that but I think I'd
want the executive stay on that
initially so once executive have said
yes we'd like to do that expression of
Interest they can just send an email out
so and then the last one really uh is
really in the gift of the leader to
Simon to do so again it is such a wish
to
thank you Marcus
Marcus for for members in so
recommendation R3
um if we are going to get that proposal
out to seek eois which is a sensible
approach in my opinion the sooner the
better because everyone's starting to
draft their budgets for next year
already and if we need to factor some
extra spending whether that be funding
the districts Rangers or whether that be
for parishes to determine if they want
to do something else we need that to
happen sooner rather than later for the
parachutes to make decisions
I think just do some caution with
recommendation three it's the
practicality of
um of coordinating I think a response
that that a meaningful response in the
Titans go so I think an expression of
interest in going out it's gauging those
um
um I think responses uh and and managing
those sponsors I'm just recollecting my
uh experience of managing and dealing
with parishes for
um
um the toilets for example the leasing
the toilets it was a long uh and drawn
out process and so you may get responses
quite quickly from some and there may be
that want to respond and they're saying
principle is a good idea but will still
take a long time to actually come back
within concrete so I think you get the
expression without interest out quickly
I think it's getting meaningful back may
take longer I think really
recommendations three should be seen as
a longer term solution I think there's a
there's a shorter term need to address
the budget for next year and then
there's a longer term lead as well
perhaps which recommendation threes is
considering
um councilor Mrs Belton um we're just
looking at the um calendar for the
overview in scrutiny the next meeting
might be too full so
um you didn't put forward any Amendment
to the recommendation so if you don't
mind I will
um that recommendation
um is re-worded to say that a further
report is presented to the next
available overview in scrutiny that's
that first sentence are you happy with
that
I am I'm just mindful that this Council
needs to set its budget so if it's got
to go to ons and then to Executive does
it have time to go to budget because
we've got people in employment here that
could be without employment if we don't
Source a budget so I just think we need
to be really mindful of time ticking and
you've got the calendar in front of you
so I'll let you guys work out what's
best but just to be mindful of the
employment is included here okay there's
some people asking questions so I'm
going to take those then we'll look at
rewording
um the recommendation if need be
um councilor Mr Morton
thank you madam chairman um look in
terms of the background of this this was
last year's topic around this time when
Essex first proposed uh doing away with
their responsibility
um it was at that time that Essex
leaders and chief Executives made strong
um opposition to the whole concept
um I wrote a letter at that time I had a
informal meeting with councilor Lee
Scott who is the highways portfolio
expressing rochford's strong
condemnation of this
um but uh and it it was extremely
disappointing
coming to the service itself I think
there's a lack of clarity about what the
service is
as far as I'm concerned there are
different areas of responsibility we
have certain public spaces that we're
responsible for Essex highways have
responsible responsibility for their
public space a lot of it being sight
lines try small spaces to allow
motorists to have good vision and
parishes have responsibility for some
areas there
uh I'm certainly with Mrs council Mrs
Mason uh on the double taxation I think
it's appalling I can't go with this
reporter tool I'm afraid uh I'm happy to
note it and but it is quite wrong that
what we are doing is no better than this
is County Council just passing them back
and saying to the parishes will you pay
for it and the reality of that is if you
look at the parishes the rural parishes
generally small populations are
disproportionate percentage increase
which impacts on people's cost of living
um within those parishes so this is
quite wrong that he is fudge that is
totally wrong someone has got to grab
hold of this and say it is a county
responsibility to manage open space that
they have responsibility for generally
through the highway system uh so I can't
agree with R3
um I think that's an excellent job was
done but it was a sticking plaster to
avoid the potential loss of jobs in
terms of the set funding it was all
always not acknowledge it would last for
about a year but it wasn't really a
permanent solution I applaud officers
and counselors at the time for coming up
with that but it was a diversion of
money from other uses let's not lose
sight of that as well so for all sorts
of reasons it is a complete mess and I
think we ought to continue to Lobby
strongly but differently from how it was
this time last year I think we ought to
hold Essex County Council to do what
they should do and and make sure that
the individual responsible bodies do
what they should do and certainly not
pass it to the parishes as a fudge from
our DC but I I it's a difficult one
thank you madam chairman
thank you
um uh councilor spering and if we can we
can try and keep things quiet short now
thank you thank you Jim uh while I have
every sympathy for councilor Mrs Mason's
comments about how to utilize the 196
000 it was made quite clear bicep that
any of these expenditures had to be to
the benefit of the highway system and if
we didn't we had to submit a list of
projects which they would sign off on if
they didn't approve them then the money
wouldn't be forthcoming just to clarify
chairman thank you
thank you Council award
thank you councilor sparing has just
clarified the question in regards to
money in regards to how highways money
must be spent thank you
Council lambon
yeah it's a important clarification on
the table appendix one
page 8.8 the maths doesn't seem to work
it comes to a 166
000 whereas the allocation was 186
000.
um also the projects that apart from the
financial support for the financial
Rangers each of the projects that are
listed there they're very round figures
have have those Works actually been
um
undertaken
and um are those figures actually
correct
Council and um Marcus will come back to
you on those ones
so there aren't there I've worked
backwards the round thing is there they
are what was requested from from the
funding so they're not they're not
precise amounts they just what's being
asked for in terms of Grants
um from from sep
um yes it's my mistake in terms of
appendix one I'm still waiting one for
the line I was just trying to um
ascertain information as to what that
additional 20 000 pounds are spent on so
my apologies I didn't add that at the
time so it's just an oversight that the
report went out sooner than I could add
that line in I do apologize
just just one very small Point again on
R3
um
if we're going out to parish and town
councils if this recommendation is
approved there's a lot of rumor and
speculation at the moment amongst the
parishes and the towns about what is
happening what is coming down the line
so I actually feel that communicating
with them at an early stage to let them
know potential situations is maybe the
right thing because if they all come
back and say categorically no we're not
prepared to fund any of this at least
this Council knows what they have one
less option to consider so whilst I
don't agree with passing money or
responsibility down the chain as Essex
have done to us and then we're
potentially looking to do I think it's
really important that we understand what
the parishes are or aren't prepared to
do good point it can strengthen our
argument um council Mrs Mason you want
to come back yes thank you for Larry to
come back I'd just like to pick up a
point that councilor Lamborn made quite
rightly he asked the officer which of
these schemes have been done
and I don't believe we've got an answer
so could we have some clarification of
that because if we have a budget that we
have to spend we should be spending it
and so my knowledge certainly some of
these haven't been done and I also must
admit I think a sign ten thousand pounds
I think that's horrendous so I hope it
didn't cost that
um so if I can bring attention to a
recommendation too
um it's about reviewing the current
allocation of surplus funding so that is
part of the review to find out what the
spend has been upon
yeah perhaps it could you tell us which
if any of those have been done
so
I I can I can try and recollect we must
understand it's not a budget I'm
responsible for um we useful to have
that question in advance I probably
could have given I'm just reluctant to
give an answer that could be wrong mayor
just come in there um perhaps um Marcus
if you could say
has anybody got any other questions
okay um I would just like to make a
couple of observations I agree with a
lot of the comments around the table
what is clear
is that our taxpayer pays Essex to look
after the roads
but we have got a problem if we say no
my fear is and it is I know our
residents they really don't know you
know who does what sometimes and they
just want it done but moreover than that
I'm just looking at only this week I was
asked how have you got on with the Hedge
fire School
so this is a hedge by a school
it I looked on to make sure that it had
been reported it was on Essex County
council's website how long will it take
them to do it now our Rangers often if I
ask them it's done within the same day
even days that's how efficient our
council is at doing Essex County
council's job but now we're not getting
paid for it
and my fear is if we don't carry this on
even if it's in the interim why we have
a big argument with Essex County Council
and make every single resident aware
that Essex County Council are not
carrying out their Duty then at least we
can keep some of those hot spot areas
which are danger
cut that's my thought so I'm going to
have to agree for this to continue in
the interim Why We Fight Essex County
Council to come to some conclusion with
some funding for doing their job
now that's over sorry am I rent
um
oh cancer sparing and uh can this be the
last question or coming please
very quickly chairman while I I share
the sentiments of people expressed here
the arrangement that was agreed some
years ago with Mr hot myself Mrs County
Council was that they would contribute
the 70 000 pounds and we would take on
the responsibility for that Duty
and that's as it stood my I'll share
your view if they've withdrawn that
funding then they've also withdrawn Our
obligation to undertake that Duty thank
you chairman
um so members we have got four
recommendations here now
um councilman Mrs Belton head asked the
officer about when the report will come
um to the next overview in scrutiny
committee and so recommendation two I'd
like to recommend an amendment which
reads the first sentence members that a
further report is presented to the next
available overview and scrutiny
committee
can read it all out have I got a second
there for that
thank you councilor Mrs Belton if all
those in favor
thank you
um I'm presuming everybody wants them
taken separately
okay recommendation number one for
members to know the report is the
Ripple noted members
thank you
a recommendation too that further report
is presented to the next available
overview and scrutiny committee
reviewing the current allocation of
surplus funding and exploring potential
savings within the Open Spaces budget
with a view to identifying possible
budget for the continuation of the
highway range of service in 2024-25 all
those in favor
oh sorry I'll propose that from the
chair I need a secondary please Council
Lamborn thank you all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions none thank you
and that motion is
10-4-2 again for that motion
recommendation sorry is covered uh
recommendation three to draft a proposal
that can be circulated to parish and
town councils seeking expressions of
Interest has set down paragraph 1.19
thank you Council cross all those in
favor
and all those against
[Music]
also list yeah so that's seven four
um five against there was no abstentions
no so that
recommendation is carried and
recommendation for that the leader of
the council writes the cabinet members
of Highways Essex County Council seeking
clarification regarding the provision of
a service with withdrawal or funding for
the highway Rangers
proposed to again from the chair second
day please thank you councilor Lamborn
all those in favor
call those against
so that's Earth seven four five against
so that recommendation is carried thank
you very much members
so if we can move on now thank you
um
Marcus for introducing that report
[Music]
thank you Chef good evening yes agenda
item nine parts of nature review
um again Marcus Hutton if you would like
to introduce this report
my apologies coming in too early there
I'm thank you chair um good evening
members again nothing to add to this
report really it's it's the noting but
uh I'm happy to take any questions thank
you
thank you members uh Council award
thank you chairman uh it's a very simple
one uh where residents have had
objections our measures being taken to
provide advise appropriate changes
um I mean certainly we're meeting with
them yes and trying to accommodate where
we can uh I think at times
um there are instances where we've met
with residents to find other residents
that are in support of what we're doing
and some that will say that they're
actually wanting to see the grass return
and other things actually like it as it
is and we don't want to see it returned
so there is a matter of compromise
um and what we do tend to do is we meet
with the lead member
um as well at the sites and then we just
we seek to compromise where we can we
can't keep everyone happy but we
certainly
um I think some of the members here have
experienced that
um reduce the amount of grass cutting or
change the shape or the design lines I
think we always said it was going to be
a very organic
um sort of process this one would
respond to the needs and experiences as
we go along
thank you just answer your question
thank you um counselor booth
Mr seeking clarification am I writing
thinking there is a difference between
not cutting and rewilding
and is there a greater cost to rewilding
rewilding him can um
um cover a range of of measures
um so not cutting the grass can be
viewed as re-wilding if you wish
um I would advise that what we do tend
to do of course is we still manage that
site so um you know it is left to grow
long but it's still annually cut and
collected and therefore there is some if
you like active management of that site
so um but nevertheless it is a form of
rewilding
um there are different levels of
intervention so I think the original
paper alluded to that so you can always
introduce um planting or Wildflower
mixes and that sort of thing or even
bulbs
um again I think initially my advice
would be that you tend to leave these
areas as long graphs initially and you
see how you go
um sometimes nature can surprise you and
the Flora responds well and you will get
a natural mix other times you have to
intervene but it it takes time so a good
example would be
um although they'll have a rewilding
scheme but it's part of that country
party is Cherry Orchard so if you if you
look at there the the sword the grass
sword you could just argue with long
grass we only cut that for height once a
year
um but over the years where you've had
the annual cut and you've managed in
that way then the the floor has improved
over the years so you know you've gone
from what was very much a mix of Road
Rules sort of um weed spaces to now um
um recorded four four or four orchid
species this year so yeah it takes time
so what starts off as looking as rank
grass and you have to keep returning to
a managing
yes thank you
Mason
yeah just a small point about the
definition of if you like of rewilding I
did speak at quite length with one of
our officer and corporate manager and it
was advised that it was exceptionally
expensive to do it properly
um
and I think it is but we're not doing
that we're not planting
um Native seeds and native plants what
we're doing is as the officer said we're
just not cutting in the hope that it
that some sort of succession will
eventually take place
um
as we're cutting less is there any uh
self-savings in this
I I mean yes I mean the original report
um alluded to that so to the
um the original parts nature report that
went to Executive predicted about a
hundred thousand pound saving and so
there's a um uh proxy 150 000 pound
savings to the grounds maintenance
regime from bringing this in thank you
Council amble
[Music]
um I may have got this wrong but
somewhere in the back of my mind this is
about what
[Music]
um
9.8
0.8 8.4 on page 9.5
um
in the back of my mind somewhere I've
heard that we've got a planning
obligation
to provide organize
Sports pitches
for the district
is this rewilding and removal of
um football pitches and whatever the
other pitches they are does that
compromise that requirement
I mean it hasn't I mean it could if you
wish to rewild everywhere but I mean we
have a playing pitch strategy to deliver
some pictures across the district which
we still honor and so certainly we
haven't taken any um active playing
pitches out of action for this scheme
council Mrs Belton thank you
um just to follow in on for Mrs Mason's
Point really and I think it's quite
important we manage expectations
regarding rewilding and not cutting
um to rewild properly as we know all of
that grass would actually need to be cut
right back to nothing and you start
again it's a process it takes a number
of years and it's not always successful
as you've alluded to it it takes
different time I think it's important
for for members that we understand what
we should be expecting because the
terminology of rewilding we kind of
expect beautiful Meadows and flowers and
flora and fauna and that's probably not
going to happen and certainly not going
to happen overnight and and take two
three years so if we are going to
attempt that I think defining where that
is likely to happen and what timeline
might be useful and budgets being set
accordingly
um but ultimately I think that the
details are within the report and
they're very useful thank you
foreign
[Music]
page uh 9.5 8.5 it is recommended that
it may be prudent to undertake a public
consultation to ascertain ascertain a
wider view from Park users particularly
if any changes are to be considered to
the existing management regime and can I
ask how will this be undertaken and just
on the back of the
um Wildflower aspect could that be
included within it to actually consult
with our residents if that's what they
would prefer
[Music]
so the consultation will take this the
um sort of format that it did previously
which was a an online consultation
that's promoted in the Parks I think I
recollect I think we had around 1500
responses so it was well it was a good
response and some very positive comments
from individuals as well so we would
take a similar approach again I think
just just touching on a again a
detailing you just want to establish
those areas initially and then you then
look at the feasibility of what you can
do with them after that and you'd want
to do pilot schemes you wouldn't say
it's very unpredictable nature so you
know um you you can't predict I I would
I wouldn't want to come to you and say
any more than I'm going to provide an
area of long grass to say that I can
then provide an area of wonderful drift
of flowers is uh a a gamble I don't want
to take because it it's it's just there
is nature of the the nutrient levels the
climates there's too many variables
there that actually you could put a lot
of seed there and it could just be eaten
by whether it's even before it even sets
seed so you know you've just got to take
its time unfortunately thank you thank
you um I think what you said about
unpredictable weather sort of some set
up really um
uh I know how quickly the grass has been
this year and I think with the rewilding
um and we discussed this before the main
problem that we had was keeping the play
areas the football pitches under control
and short I think the office has done an
admirable job and have now scheduled in
more Cuts so that should help our
residents oh sorry councilman Mrs Mason
you want to come back on something
I'd I'd just like to
have some greater Clarity and
consideration to the consultation when
the parts for nation was first mooted
um I know we had the online consultation
but I go over my local park nearly daily
and I took it on myself to ask residency
if they knew about poses not one person
using the park knew about the proposals
so whilst we may have had a substantial
response it's not necessary from the
people that use the facilities so I
would like to see if there is further
consultation that it's actually done in
person as well or so that we actually
consult with the people that are using
the facilities rather than people that
might have an opinion on rewarding thank
you
um I greet you to some content context
because whether it's my area said that
they hadn't heard of it even though I
had shared the
um the consultation myself I think us as
Ward councilors could probably take that
role on as opposed to officers because
their capacity and talk to people we can
also perhaps um markers consider having
our posters QR codes that sort of thing
to encourage people actually in the
Parks because people are going to look
at that and think what's that and
hopefully contribute that way as they're
over
um are there any more please keep it
very short please Council lord it's
going to be very short yeah I was
hesitating to bring this one forward but
I mean on the mention of Woodland areas
and grasses I would assume and I would
need to a lesson on this one is mayor's
tale a grasp because I know it's quite
invasive in wyburn's Woodland
um and I know it does carry around
um
I just want to a view with regard to
that type of grass
I know it's an ancient grass
prehistorically
thank you
going slightly off topic but um but I
will answer there's no grass you're
testing my memories of taxonomy now I
think it's a gym that join us Fern I
think from memory so but it's a it's
it's a type of ancient fern
thank you Marcus and I'm sure if Council
has got any more questions off topic you
can ask outside of this meeting
um so members um there is one
recommendation set at page 9.1 of the
report to note the findings of the
report are these noted please members
thank you
members um agenda item number 10 the
scope and document for a few of the
council's outside bodies
um you've all got the document and you
have had it in your pack members are
there any questions on the scoping
document
Council Orton
thank you madam chairman
um generally happy with the document um
but I will just raise
um under the terms of reference in that
first section in terms of what the
review will examine and that first
bullet point I find it a little strange
um I.E acella
um I is not EG and I think it should
probably be EG
that is to say as opposed to for example
yeah
so I think it's the wrong initials there
if that's agreed
um as seller we are one-seventh part of
a seller so it's not a good example to
put it there because it's a partnership
of which we are one-seventh and I think
there's plenty of examples to use I'm
just going to interject today
um is it an outside body that we attend
no
it isn't an outside body that we attend
and we are one-seventh of a seller it
isn't an outside body in the way other
outside bodies and I look to the
monitoring officers for assistance on
that but we are one seventh under a
constituted Arrangement
um so I just don't think it's a good
example of outside body but I will look
for to the monitoring officer to give
some guidance to me
um taking on board where you've just
said um councilor Wootton
um I propose and I will need a second
year that the review title is amended
review of the council's outside bodies
and a seller
do I have a secondary place
thank you councilor Myers
um
yes council Mrs Mason can I just say
that there may be and I think there's
possibly others that are Partnerships as
opposed to outside bodies and I think it
would be I certainly know that the
seller was intended to be included in
this so if we could perhaps we would
refer to the monitoring officers as a
review of outside bodies and perhaps
partnership agreements would that be the
central Council written
more than happy with that now even guess
if I say I'll second it but
that is absolutely perfect I'm quite
happy to withdraw what I proposed so um
it now the title will now read review of
the council's outside bodies and
Partnerships all in agreement
wonderful thank you so moving swiftly on
are there any other questions on this
report
so members is the report noted
yes thank you thank you just for the mic
all nodding at me doesn't work sometimes
um a gender item 11 key decisions
documents uh members are there any
questions on the key decisions document
I can go through it if you would like me
to that you have Gotti in front of you
foreign
[Music]
for when the decision is to be made
and I noticed this is actually wrong
it's got portfolio holder
um actually this is totally wrong it
should have unless I've got the wrong
copy it should have the lead member
against it which the one I've got on my
computer did have this is this is the
wrong document that's been circulated to
myself I don't know if everyone else has
got the same one
that it should have
yes
um the decision maker should be
executive with the league member
um identified in Brackets underneath
and in future the if the date is changed
because there has been a propensity for
the date to be altered
then it has been agreed that the reason
for that date change will also be put in
the report so that we will have greater
Clarity
um I don't know where the correct
document is but it's not substantially
different is all I can say
I'm happy to come back on that chair
firstly committee members just an
apology
um that perhaps an earlier iteration of
the work plan
um key decisions document sorry has been
circulated and just to confirm councilor
Mrs Mason's comments that yes we will be
referring to the members of the
executive with their current title which
is lead member
um and I absolutely agree agree that
um a very important part of good
governance is to track where the key
decisions have been delayed or moved in
the scheduled uh date of decision that
we show that indicated decisions
document because whilst it might be
apparent for those of us that have the
conversation we need to make sure that
it's very clear for the public where our
intended day of decision making has has
slipped or has moved for some some
reason
thank you um are you happy with that
response council Mrs Mason yes I'm more
than happy I have seen the amended
document so it's just someone's picked
up the wrong ones for printing it's an
error it happens thank you
Council cross
um yeah just just um small Point
um I in an effort to save a few
rainforests um I've been diligently
using my cmis
um because I was told to
um but that item is is missing in in the
documents it's not exempt obviously
um
this is a difficult one in previous
years the key decision document is on
there but it hasn't come out with the
pack I can assure you that it will do in
future
counselors uh sparing thank you chairman
uh again I'm not quite sure where my
comments fit into the latest scenario
whether it comes into the work plan
or to key decisions but uh back in March
April time we had quite a lengthy
discussion about blue blue badge parking
restrictions and implementation a
subsequent report was supposed to be
coming unless I've missed it I can't
remember seeing that there was also
going to be another one about amendments
to the volunteer policy
I don't know whether that one's been
slid through and that I haven't seen
sorry counselor are you talking about
the work plan now well I say I'm not
quite sure
whether it where it comes in that's why
I'm asking questions it's item number 12
from work okay fine thank you um was
there any other comments or anything
from um item 11
fine so now we're on to agenda item 12
the work plan so you believe there's
items missing from the work plan uh yes
chairman um there's a one that we have
quite a lengthy conversation I think you
you were front and center on it in
relation to periods of three hour
parking for blue badges and there was
supposed to be a subsequent report
coming forward after various uh
questions have been asked and a number
of people with blue badges there was
also amendments being requested for the
council's volunteer policy
um at the same time and also chairman I
have a question and again I'm not quite
sure how I can where I can put this
back in March April time the council was
trying to put together a glyphosphate
policy I don't know where that's
progressed
purely as councilor ward has mentioned
there is a huge problem with this
particular weed Fern or whatever it is
all over the district and while I
appreciate glyphosphate isn't used by
the district council any further than it
needs to be
it is the only thing that I as I
understand will have any effect on
mayor's tail on his control and on
Japanese knotweed now
for years the district council has
supported towns and parishes in the
control of this
pest for one of a better phrase I've now
been told that they will no longer
support the parishes
so where do we go what advice the only
advice I've received so far is that we
should use a flame gun
in the middle of summer which I didn't
think was the the best idea so I'll
leave that one with you chairman yep so
um the blue badge I do recall that it
was on there so um if we can have that
put back onto the work plan
Emily can give an update on the blue
badge report
um thank you chair so when the overview
of the scrutiny committee called in the
portfolio holder decision on the blue
badge parking there were two
recommendation or there were a number of
recommendations that came out of that
one of which was that a report exploring
all the options goes to the full Council
so it wasn't an item to come back to
overview and scrutiny it was an item to
move into full Council for this
discussion
um and with regards to the portfolio
holder decision that was called in and
then kind of referred back to the
executive that is now in the process of
being implemented fine
Jeff I might well I've just got the
floor the other two the volunteering
policy I need to go back and refresh
myself what the recommendations from the
committee were and I'm not even going to
attempt with the other one and I think
I'll take that offline if that's okay
certainly thank you sorry
any other question uh Council Ward
thank you very much chairman
um yeah it's something I'd like to see
added uh to the work
stream and that is on the 2nd of
November we have planning enforcement
update can I also ask we have a
development management uh update on the
service review which I know has been
taking place
in theory yes
um if we can just let officers
um come back to us if it's possible to
produce the report for us by the second
November if you're telling me the work's
been Undertake and then it should be but
I don't want to actually put them on the
spot to come back on the second if it's
not but it can be put into this year's
work plan
why not they come back
um it was started
prior to it was May prior to May it's a
March April time we got the review on
the go so I would hope we would have
some answers in regards to that service
review
thank you yes we will ask officers see
when they can bring It Forward of course
we've also got the report now that um
can come forward perhaps on the 2nd of
November that we discussed earlier on so
that's something else for our work plan
any other
questions or comments members
and I do believe
that with that that is the end of our
meeting for this evening thank you very
much
um we did a lot of work tonight and have
a lovely evening